to the guys that say there are women who
say they want vulnerability and then as
soon as I actually cry not cute cry
they're out I don't think there's
someone who is capable of having a real
relationship I think that's a woman who
says that she wants a real relationship
but hasn't grown enough to truly
understand men and truly understanding
men might be understanding that there
are some things you will or won't like
and also that there are parts of him
that are very much not different from
you at all and if you're looking for
someone who's bulletproof and strong all
the time then there's some growing up to
do
you are one of the best known dating
coaches on the planet how many clients
have you worked with
all worked with I don't know it must be
hundreds of thousands but Millions
online I think we've got about eight
million people that follow and half a
billion views now on YouTube which is
crazy Lots so you mostly work with women
if because of that if anybody has an
insight into the psychology of females
in the modern dating Market that should
be you
given that you've been doing this for 15
years what are the biggest changes that
you have seen in what women want during
that time
hmm
and what women want I suppose
I don't think a lot changes about what
people want
but I suppose if I were to make a
cultural observation it would be
it would come up for people that
how do I find someone who's either
playing at my level
or someone who accepts My Level whether
it's financially or what I've achieved
in my life the work that I do that's
something that you know is obviously a
modern day thing
and I think a lot of people are asking
how do I find someone who's not
intimidated
by
where I am in my life what do you mean
by that be specific
that I earn more potentially as a woman
as a woman
that I have
a high status job not everyone but
there's a decent amount of that of
people worrying that
they're either going to intimidate
someone or they're proactively looking
for someone that
is playing at their level
it's hard sometimes to say whether
that's because they want they genuinely
want someone who's playing at their
level
or because they're just worried that if
they find someone who's not playing at
their level that person is going to have
an issue with it
you know what I mean what's the a woman
struggling to be attracted to guys that
don't have that level of Education don't
have that level of employment that they
do are they struggling to date down so
to speak from an attraction point of
view yes
I mean look there has to be some I know
that I've spoken to very successful
groups of business women who are really
playing at a high level and
sometimes in those circles which by the
way I don't think a tip you know like
the ultra ultra high achieving like
Taipei you're in that like you know made
millions of dot like that's a unique
group of people but I have experience
being in those circles where one of the
first things I get asked is well how do
I find someone who is also
you know playing at this level and I
I always feel like saying at that point
isn't surely the reason to achieve all
of this is so that you can choose anyone
you want
not so that you can kind of go now that
I'm in this top 0.5
I need to find someone in that top five
percent
in a socio-economic sphere I I always
think that's a
to me the reason to make money
the reason to build something or to just
have a job that takes care of you and
your family potentially is so that you
never need that from another person
and then you're free
then you can really go who is it I
actually want who do I admire
who shows up powerfully in my life
and I think that you know sometimes I've
seen people too narrowly Define
what they see as powerful yeah an
attraction well you know fundamentally
there are certain elements of Attraction
for men and for women women tends to be
status and resources for men it tends to
be Youth and fertility and looks these
things aren't completely unmallowable
you can change these things you can
nudge your preferences
um but yeah I can see how increasing
female achievement would mean that they
do have that reduced pool of men so if
those are the things with regards to
what women want what else has changed
what have been the biggest changes from
when you've been interacting with your
clients the dating landscape generally
that have happened from when you started
until now look when I started you know
15 years ago the apps weren't a thing
dating sites were
but it was still
there was a kind of almost a you didn't
want people to know you were on a dating
site you might have been on one but you
didn't talk about it that's gone
like no one's why people hate dating
a lot of the time they're burned out on
them they they don't want to necessarily
be there but there's not the shame that
goes with like I'm on hinge I'm on
Tinder I'm on it's just it's like this
thing I have to do and I sort of resent
having to do it that's how that's a lot
of people's relationship with it
so that's changed the relationship with
it is not I'm hiding it it's just I
don't want to have to do it
what I think is newer because I you know
I've thought about this I thought is
there anything new to add to the
conversation of
what's changed in dating but
the looks aspect might have changed
never have we been so capable
of having the tools to change how we
look
online
on our Instagram on our profiles that is
like
We There were some people that maybe
years ago were really quite Adept at
making themselves look their best
in person
in when they were posting pictures even
like oh well both in person and and in
their dating profiles
but I remember
match.com back years ago I don't know if
they still say it but they used to say
you know I think they had like 18 slots
for uploading photos and their whole
thing was the more photos you upload the
more
trust your building and people will
really essentially get a good look at
you and it's going to result in more
matches
and the less you have the more it's like
people are like wait how do they look
and do they
I don't know that that holds true
anymore
because these days someone could have an
entire Instagram profile man or woman
and you just don't know what they look
like until you meet them in person
we have so many tools now to change how
we look and
that has different implications for one
it's sort of homogenized looks
so if everyone is trying to look if like
we've decided that this is what the
fashionable look is right now
then
everyone sort of starts molding on not
everyone but a lot of people start
molding themselves to look like that so
there's a kind of in the same way that
globalization meant that every town you
showed up to had a Starbucks and this
and that and every town started looking
the same I feel like that's happened
with people online or there's like a
globalization of looks
it also means that we have this standard
not just we have more insecurity about
ourselves and our looks because we're
looking at everyone else going I don't
look like that
but it's also created this crazy
standard when it comes to what we're
looking for
and who we're looking for
because we are now looking we're like
chasing
this image that that isn't even that
person
and I I I find it's true of everything
in life now it's like true of Santorini
you like Santorini can't compete with
Instagram Santorini
I saw pictures yesterday on Instagram of
New England in the fall
now
Audrey and I have like we're excited to
go to New England in the fall I've been
here a long time Audrey's newer to the
states and I want to like show her the
east coast in the full time and I was
about to show her these photos of New
England in the fall and then I was like
something doesn't look right about these
photos there were these pinks
that were insane I was like they caught
that and then I started looking at the
comments and there were just so many
people going I live in New England and
it is beautiful in the fall but it looks
nothing like none of these pinks I don't
know where they've come from yeah and so
when you look at that you go oh that's a
real shame
because if you're going to New England
and now you're kind of looking for this
version of New England that doesn't
exist
and you'll see you're sort of deflated
or disappointed even though New England
is stunning
in the fall that's a that's a that's a
bad situation to be in so I feel like
there's a kind of a correction we have
to do with ourselves these days
especially if we live a lot online
for reality
versus what we're seeing otherwise we're
going to go we're not just going to go
around insecure that we don't live up to
something we're going to go around super
entitled that someone else doesn't live
up to this impossible thing obviously do
you think that online dating profiles
Instagram has skewed expectations of
what people think that they should get
in a relationship I think so I think so
you sing this with your clients
I don't know I I don't know if I have a
lot of anecdotal evidence
for that explicitly but I just think the
more
it can't not be true on some level
the the more we all see
because it's true on things outside of
Romance the more we see people driving
crazy cars and they look like they're on
vacation all the time and we don't know
when they work because they always seem
to be by a pool somewhere sipping a
cocktail the more you think there must
be something wrong with your life that
you know I why aren't I getting that
much vacation or why am I not enjoying
that life what's and I think there must
be so we feel entitled to that life
where we're not working really hard to
get there and whatever because no one's
showing that I there has to be a
romantic equivalent to that what do you
think that men misunderstand about what
women want right now
hmm
if men
I suppose the more men are chasing these
ideas of
flashiness or you know they see
Instagram accounts that are like always
some guy posing by a car or a plane or
some amazing lifestyle whatever I
I kind of think the more people just
become indoctrinated that with that idea
that this must these are symbols of
what's attractive
and it's true for a group of people that
there are there are some people that
that's true for so that validates it
and especially when you're seeing
those guys with women that are beautiful
and that might be considered like the
most desirable people then you're
thinking oh that must be what's
attractive but I think that becomes this
becomes this sort of rabbit hole you can
go down
where you spend a life impressing or
trying to impress living to impress
someone that is gonna like ultimately
make you incredibly unhappy
and I think that's prob that is the
disconnect I think that happens for a
a lot of guys
it's a bit like the vulnerability
conversation
that when a guy
I've been vulnerable in my life before
with the wrong people
and it
backfired
I've been vulnerable where I've stressed
in a relationship and insecurity
and
I'm thinking this is you know this is me
being real this is me being raw this is
me saying something that's upset me or
made me jealous or made me insecure
and I've gone into that thinking this is
good this is the kind of relationship
that I'm told we should be having a
vulnerable one an honest one
and I've had it really backfire in my
life where it was quite clear that the
person saw me as less attractive after
having said the thing than they did
before
and at the time
I wasn't in my stage of evolution as a
man today at the time it just made me go
never again
I am never being that honest again that
was too much she didn't want that level
of honesty she wanted a cute version of
vulnerability an endearing version of
kind of crying in in the movie you know
version of vulnerability but not like
I'm actually insecure about something
but I learned the wrong lesson that day
because it was wrong
for that person it wasn't they weren't
ready for that they weren't they they
were still in a
a mindset of not looking for kind of a
complete person
and that was that was them and I wasn't
I I wasn't strong enough in my own frame
at the time
to be like oh that means this person is
not right for me instead I went oh my
God I'm hideous deficient yeah and I'll
never I'll never say that stuff again
but that these days when I look at my
relationship now one of the things I'm
most grateful for is that I really can
be me I truly the things that I thought
no that's too shame for
now that's to
that's like you know that is definitely
on the opposite end of masculine strong
guy like those things
are celebrated as much as the rest of me
and that has been like a that has been a
life-changing thing for me so I think
that guys don't just get it wrong from
what's portrayed they get it wrong from
experiences they've had
with people that they should never have
ended up with or with someone that
wasn't ready in their life someone is is
showing vulnerability unattractive
is men showing vulnerability to women
unattractive how do men how do women
perceive this balance of confidence and
vulnerability
well I think it's attractive to the
right women who truly believe that I
think that look no one wants there's a
distinction to be made there's the
vulnerability of I have something that I
struggle with
and
I'm being open with you about that
that's vulnerability
telling someone 10 times a day like but
do you think this and do you think that
and I that's not that ceases to be
vulnerability that's just what I think
of as like dumping neediness it was just
it's it's a fun it's a kind of mutation
because vulnerability is like a form of
openness I'm letting you in I'm letting
you into my mind I'm letting you into
the things that I struggle with I'm
letting you into the battles that I
fight
but when we're kind of dumping on
someone we're making them responsible
for solving it for us
and that ceases to be vulnerability
that's kind of an abdication of
responsibility I actually think it's an
incredibly attractive thing for anyone
in a relationship man or woman to be
like I struggle with this
and it's something that I'm working on
because then you're you're taking
ownership of it it may be from something
you didn't create it might be from a
childhood wound it might be from trauma
you suffered growing up it might be from
any of those things it might not be your
fault
that you have that thought pattern or
that wiring but there's a different you
can say something's not my fault and
still say I'm gonna own it and I'm gonna
work on dealing with this because it's
mine to deal with
when you do that in a relationship I
think that's a very powerful thing but I
think people confuse the two it's it
can't be accept me at any cost
it can't be I have I can make your life
miserable with all of the things that
I'm struggling with all the time
and if you don't tolerate that
the problem is you we'll get back to
talking to Matthew in one second but
first I need to tell you
I need to tell you about L come on I
need to tell you about element element
is a science-backed electrolyte ratio of
sodium potassium and magnesium with none
of the junk no coloring no artificial
ingredients no gluten no fillers and no
BS they are the exclusive hydration
partner to Team USA weightlifting and
rely done by tons of Olympic athletes
and high performers all around the world
it'll help to regulate your appetite
it'll curb Cravings it'll help your
brain health everything about it I
absolutely adore it every single morning
it is the way that I start my day even
video guiding uses it and it tastes
fantastic that orange flavor is
absolutely phenomenal they also have a
no BS no questions asked refund policy
where if you do not like it for any
reason they will give you your money
back and you don't even need to return
the box that's how certain they are that
you'll love it head to drink lmnt.com
modern wisdom to get a free sample pack
of all eight flavors with your first box
that's drink
lmnt.com
modern wisdom
do you find your
client saying that they wish that men
opened up more or less on average do you
think more
100 more hey there's a real yearning for
men to talk more
to be more open to be more vulnerable to
actually communicate more and what about
to the men who say I've heard stories
like you're one where a woman says that
they love the idea of me opening up and
the second that they do they see me as
the beta male underling yeah that I've
always feared that they might do it
maybe confirms my concerns that I have
about being insufficient therefore I'm
going to lock this away yeah or I
say these things and they think I'm
awful you know there's things that I'm
going to say to you that I don't
normally say because I think they
they're a part of my past that I don't
like and you're gonna now think I'm
villainous you know there's that too and
I there's that's a hundred percent gonna
happen with some people
100 there are going to be people you
come up against who
you tell them something from your past
and they go
you're awful
who who doesn't have something that they
look back on and go I really was a [__]
to someone I really was mean to someone
I really I regret that deeply
I should never have done this I should
never have done that
but what we want is to be able to meet
someone in life who can make space for
those parts of us and to the guys that
say there are women who say they want
vulnerability and then as soon as I
actually cry not cute cry
they're out I I don't think there's
someone who is capable of having a real
relationship I don't think that's I
think that's a woman who says that she
wants a real relationship but is hasn't
grown enough to truly understand men
and truly understanding men might be
understanding that there are some things
you will or won't like
and also that there are parts of him
that are very much not different from
you at all
and and if you're looking for someone
who's Bulletproof
and strong all the time
then there's some growing up to do
well there will be men out there that
are like that bulletproof yeah there are
men out there I have a number of friends
that range from totally emotional to
completely unemotional and the ones some
of them that are completely unemotional
I believe that that's actually how they
are that there is a degree of
um ease with their emotions they just
don't seem to hold on to things things
don't seem to affect them in as deep of
a way as some of my other friends so I
suppose that
there is a market for each different
type of person if you're a guy who is
super emotional if you are one who has
vulnerabilities issues from your past
you need to work on finding a partner
who is going to be able to accept that
well that yeah I mean that's in that's
kind of the whole
the whole game of dating and
relationships is
what kind of person you actually want
whatever Society is telling you is
attractive or whatever your friends are
telling you is attractive you can you
can find someone who makes you
incredibly happy and your friends are
like really I don't get it I you know
like I don't know really and that if
unless you have a strong sense of self
and of what you're looking for that
could throw you off that could make you
go oh yeah you're right I guess this
person isn't great but five minutes ago
you thought they were awesome because
they were right for you and okay fine if
there's someone that's if there's a guy
that's kind of like that won't show
emotion and doesn't need to indulge
emotions and whatever
that's okay
but if you're a woman dating that guy
you better be damn sure that you don't
want the kind of relationship that has a
lot of emotional intimacy
you that that's really what it comes
down to when you talk about a guy like
that I go that's a guy I'd never be
close friends with
because I'm not like that I'm like a you
know I'm a crier I'm someone who I cry
at everything weeper yeah I am and but
you know but that's who I am and so I I
like being oh if you look at the pattern
of all of my male friendships
they're all people that we can sit
together one-on-one and have really
meaningful open compass don't vulnerable
conversations so if you're a woman
looking for that I as a man I know I'm
looking for that if you're a woman
looking for that then
you have to you have to look at that
from the beginning
and say have I seen any evidence in the
first three weeks of the fact that I'm
talking with someone who can relate on
that level or am I
or is it just someone who's hot yeah and
successful and charismatic or whatever
and I've said on the eligible bachelor
test this person ticks every box because
that's a big thing that there's a big
thing around oh they're super eligible
and then you have to step back and go
what does that mean
when you say they're eligible a lot of
the time when someone says someone's
eligible they mean that they're single
that they're age appropriate that they
are successful or at the very least are
successful in their world or in whatever
they do
and
um
that they're attractive
that's what eligible means none of those
things barring being able to be take
care of oneself
none of those things have any bearing on
how great the relationship's going to be
and yet people in early dating invest
based on these markers of Eligibility
and it blinds them to all of these
things they don't have like for example
emotional vulnerability or communication
what are the most common traits that
people
find attractive or optimized for on the
front end that don't have predictive
power at making a relationship work long
term in your opinion hmm
I won't say it has no predictive power
but chemistry is wildly overrated what's
chemistry
well that's the point
it's not easy to put your finger on but
for people will describe it as it's uh
you know
this feeling I get when I'm with them
this this attraction this spark this
connection this sometimes when people
are talking about chemistry they're
talking about animal attraction other
times when people talk about chemistry
they're talking about this just deep
sense of
feeling really connected to someone but
the point is those things that are
really hard to describe
they can be describing a lot of
different things and and chemistry may
be necessary it might be a box you need
to tick
in other words I have a sexual
attraction to this person there's a box
you need to tick if you want real a
long-term romantic relationship
but it's not a good indicator of whether
it's going anywhere
whether someone has the same intentions
as you whether someone has the same
vision as you whether they'd make a
great partner
and all of those things are the big
things that
attraction or let's say attention
because when you have chemistry you get
someone's attention
attention is not intention and that is a
big mistake that people make we have the
most amazing time together we're so
connected when we're together Sparks are
flying that says nothing about that
person's intention with you what are
they actually looking for what's their
goal here an intention even when there's
aligned intentions intention doesn't
equal investment
you can have someone who says all the
right things and I really want to be
with you and but they can't back it up
when it comes to actually being
consistent when it comes to uh
progressing things with you when it
comes to making any kind of sacrifice
when it comes to exclusivity they can't
deliver and that we make so many
mistakes in early dating by thinking
that we have all three of those things
when actually all we have is someone's
attention
and usually for sporadic moments
what are the most common complaints that
you're hearing from the women that you
coach about the men that they're dating
what are the issues that they're coming
up against most frequently
um
I suppose they're not ready
they don't want to commit
I want something meaningful I want
something that's actually going to go
somewhere and this person is just kind
of stringing me along or they can't seem
to they a lot of people wouldn't frame
it like this person stringing me along
because that kind of there's a hard
thing to admit but they may say this
person keeps saying they're not ready
and they're just not quite there yet and
they're not sure and so I think the
indecisiveness of men and the inability
to actually
commit is that's gotta be
the top one I would say well that would
run counter a little bit to a lot of
what you hear about on the internet
which would be that most men are
struggling to find a date that they
can't get attention from women that
women are actually looking for attention
from the top man as much as possible and
in my experience this you know I've
stood on the front door of a thousand
events and met a million people across
my entire life
you know 18 to 21 year olds guys and
girls aren't exactly known for their
maturity especially not in the UK
especially not when they're drunk and
yet in my experience
most of the girls even at that age were
looking for maybe it wasn't a
particularly mature form of commitment
but they were looking for commitment
they're looking for a guy that they
could hold hands with and go away to a
little summer vacation with and do
Christmas markets in December
it seems to me that a lot of the
a lot of the concerns that guys have
around what women want and the issues
that they're facing
don't seem to match up massively what
are the concerns that guys have
I think that the big ones are that
they're not going to be found attractive
that they're going to be seen as creepy
if they approach them that if they try
to do online dating that they're not
going to be responded to if they try to
approach them in the real world that
they're going to be seen as some metoo
Predator that she is going to trade up
because there is an endless hierarchy of
guys that could fly her out to Dubai
there's some shake on the other side of
Instagram that's going to dhammer and
put her on a five-star flight to to take
her out to Dubai and uh that you know
this is this is the world that we live
in now that girls have more
opportunities than ever before because
it's been afforded by social media which
means that the top few guys are going to
eat and everybody else is going to
starve I sympathize I with guys on all
of those things I I feel I really it
touches me when you say it because I I
think that there is
it's a really hard thing
for anyone to feel invisible
and and what's more to feel like even if
I'm briefly visible I will become
invisible again the moment this person
comes across someone with more
and when I
hear that
I come to two immediate conclusions one
is
choose well
choose someone as a man who truly
is you know one of the phrases Audrey
used all the time when we were dating
and getting to know each other she kept
saying as a philosophy for her life
I just believe in chasing the right
things
that you will always be kind of not
punished but life will always like give
you its comeuppance if you chase the
wrong things
and you'll always have to end up at some
point circling back to the right thing
it's just when you just decide to do it
and
I've come to look at that as like one of
my key mantras for life I look at all
the time am I chasing the right thing or
the wrong thing here and I think that a
lot of guys are struggling
because they're chasing the wrong thing
um
they themselves you know it's
there is an entitlement among a lot of
guys that
I
I should have this
and it we the funny thing about dating
is that we end up accusing each other of
exactly the thing that we're doing
and we really hate the other side for
doing it
but it is exactly what we're doing it's
one Community saying it's disgraceful
how shallow they are
I have to be a certain height for them
to even pay attention to me
and meanwhile they're going
why don't I have the top one percent of
women
you're going what are you talking about
it's literally you just did exactly the
same thing you just said there was a top
one percent and you're not interested in
the rest
that there is a hip-hop on both sides
there is a hypocrisy there
that I really struggle with and I think
the more
we can get to a point where we go what
are the counter-cultural compromises
that I am willing to make in order to
actually live a happy life
not
a life that everyone else says is so
impressive
not a life where I finally go look I
made it I'm dating the cheerleader
a life that's actually making you happy
because you've you've selected for the
right things
what counter-cultural compromises will
you have to make for that
we talked earlier about because I know
for me I'm all about looking at that on
both sides
we talked earlier about women who
might
say well I want to date someone who's at
my level
and I want to go well let's redefine
what you class as your level do you mean
your level for kindness
your level for generosity your level for
empathy
your level for being loyal
or do you mean your level of income
because the things I said first will
make you far happier
this thing doesn't really matter
but you've told yourself it matters now
could you make a compromise that goes
against the grain
because that that is what if if we go
online and we look at all of these
communities is everyone arguing to me
there's from the outside because I don't
I'm not deep in these things but I know
I hear it's like I hear second hand all
the time so you can always correct me if
I'm getting it wrong on what people are
saying out there
but when I look at it I feel like so
much debate is being had at the macro
level
of here's how men are here's how women
are and hear all the things we can't
stand about the cultural norm right now
and
when I look at that I'm like this feels
to me
like in if it was the business
equivalent
it's like I want to start a sandwich
shop
and I spend all my time
watching the news
and the economy
and the macro statistics
and saying this is why I shouldn't start
a sandwich shop
this is why you can't start a sandwich
shop today look at it I'm watching the
news all day and it's terrible or you
know the banking system is going to
collapse soon you know that right no
point starting a sandwich shop now or
constantly arguing about politics and
who's in government
oh it's the Democrat oh it's not
business friendly oh you don't want to
be in California it's not business
friendly right I'm not going to start a
business in California like does does
that mindset and I have always one of
the reasons that I've always loved
studying things from a place of
curiosity and that's what you do you
you're facet you're a curious person
who's fascinated by
how things work and why things are
happening so I get the that part I
understand
but when people are complaining
constantly about the macro of it all and
that becomes their excuse
I always just think do you realize that
your life changes by what you do in the
micro if you're a woman and you're
saying men are always intimidated by me
I say in the macro you're 100 right
that there is an awful lot of men if
you're a high earner if you're a high
status if you've done a lot in your life
oof there's going to be a lot of men who
are intimidated by you that's 100 true
so I would never want to invalidate that
but on the micro
if you're telling me that men are always
intimidated by you
something's going wrong
well who's the common denominator
between all of these men
right now you could say men are the the
gender is the common denominator is men
men have a problem with this none of my
female friends have a problem with this
men have a problem with this but but I
look at that and I go
there is a way to either you're going
for a certain kind of guy all the time
or you're going in with that as your
kind of power and that is your value and
that's the thing you talk about all the
time no one wants to go out with a rich
person who talks about how much money
they have
no one
no one wants to go out with a celebrity
who talks about how famous they are you
you want to go out with someone who has
a conversation with you and gets to know
you and is interested in you and is
impressed by you
right that's one of the most attractive
things in the world is you go on it like
people should go on a date asking
themselves how could I be impressed by
this person
and if you do that and there was a
writer friend of mine who used to work I
think he wrote for The Hollywood
Reporter or someone but he used to say
when he would interview celebrities the
goal for himself so that he could write
a good piece was always to go because he
didn't care he'd been doing it so long
it was for him it was like just another
person coming through the door with a
movie it long past the point of having
any novelty for him
but he would say could by the end of
this interview
could I get to a place of feeling
grateful for having been here
and he knew that the key to accessing
that gratitude was fine feeling like by
the end of the time with that person
they had taught him something they had
given him some kind of Life perspective
or told him their story in a way that
made him feel like wow
I'm actually really grateful I got to
sit with this person he said if I could
achieve that gratitude I knew that the
article I would write
would convey that I knew it would be a
good piece
I think that we could approach dating
that way but so many people go on a date
and it's like here's what's impressive
about me
here's why here's here's why you should
feel a little intimidated by me instead
of going how can I how can I show I'm
impressed by you or how can I show that
there's something about you that just
wow that's really interesting or that I
have a unique understanding of You by
the end of the date that's super
attractive it makes someone feel seen
that taking go back to our example if
you're someone who let's say is real you
have a job that intimidates people
you also have immense leverage in being
able to reverse that
by the way that you are on a date with
someone and so that to me is always
for me on the front lines of dating
where I'm constantly helping people to
actually go out there and find love
I always want to say to them forget the
news
look at what's what are the things you
could do
to transform your dating life and it's
it's wild how much you can do to
transform your dating life and it
doesn't matter what's going on out there
there's this phrase that a doctor friend
of mine used when it came to diseases in
hospitals he said statistics don't
matter to the individual if you've if
you get one in a thousand disease
it doesn't matter to you that is one in
a thousand you'll you have the disease
but I actually from a dating perspective
like to put a positive spin on that
regardless of how Grim things seem out
there
the statistic doesn't matter to the
individual if you as an individual learn
how to be more proactive in your love
life you learn how to be a beautiful
presence on a date you learn how to
attract someone those statistics are not
going to be the primary thing affecting
your love life we'll get back to talking
to Matthew in one minute but first I
need to tell you about a product I've
used every single day for three years
now to help support my health and my
nutrition and that's ag1 by athletic
greens even with the best of intentions
I don't get enough fruit and vegetables
in my diet I don't know if anybody does
and ag-1 helps to fill those nutritional
gaps and just make me feel more
confident that every single day I'm
covering all of my bases ag1 is a
life-changing nutritional habit it's got
75 vitamins minerals and Whole Food
sourced ingredients including a
multivitamin multi-mineral pre and
probiotic green superfood blend and more
that all work together to fill the
nutritional gaps in your diet it is the
most comprehensive all-in-one daily
powder that I've ever tried I always
wondered why guys like Tim Ferriss and
Andrew hubman and Joe Rogan were talking
about it and after trying pretty much
every other drink on the market I can
see why it is the best tasting and most
comprehensive that I've ever found also
there is a 90-day money-back guarantee
so you can buy it and try it for 89 days
and if you do not like it they will give
you your money back head to
athleticgreens.com wisdom to get a
Year's free supply of vitamin D 5 free
travel packs and more that's
athleticgreens.com
[Music]
wisdom remember as well that at the
moment the same news the same macro
weather report is being
absorbed by a lot of other people that
are in the dating market so this is a
mental model I learned from David
Goggins and he was saying it's so easy
to be great nowadays because most people
are weak and Dana White said something
similar which was he advises his sons if
you are even remotely a Savage you will
run these people over because the bar is
set so low so think about the fact that
there are some challenging times and
some turbulence in the dating Market
which causes a lot of people to have a
sense of
um
they abandon any personal agency that
they have I can't affect this I'm at the
mercy of the weather and it's going to
blow me around okay
reverse that and think the bar is set so
low because almost everybody else
believes this so if I put a tiny
nanogram of effort into what I do I will
separate myself out from the pack it's
it's the same thing with guys that are
struggling with attraction I'm like if
you go to the gym three times a week for
a year you are probably in the top
percentile of all men on the planet with
regards to Fitness
180 minutes a week for you like the bar
is set so low for this stuff and
it is
easy for you to separate yourself out
from the pack if that's the case so you
can use the concerns you can use that as
a litmus test to think well okay those
are the things to avoid doing
I know that if I do something that's
even marginally different to that if I
do show up differently on a date if I do
take care of my appearance if I do try
and be kind and compassionate because
apparently women say that that's
something that they're that they're
struggling for at the moment let's
stress test this for myself and another
thing is that
because people have retreated into
online dating so much and so few people
are going out and actually having
interactions in the real world
where's any evidence to stress test any
of the ideas that you've learned from
the stuff that you've heard on the
internet like the most egregious Stories
the ones that are terrifying and make
you worried about the dating Market
quite rightly are the ones that get a
hundred thousand upvotes on Reddit
because they're insane they're egregious
and incredible and terrifying okay well
has that ever happened in your life do
you ever know anyone that has happened
to apart from that person that's on
Reddit that person doesn't count like
anyone that you know personally and
there will be some people that stories
come from somewhere some people will
know that guy
not many people and lots and lots and
lots of people very few of them have
encountered any of the nightmare
scenarios that are spoken about but
people use the stories that they hear on
the internet as representative for what
they can expect in the real world of
dating yeah and that's very dangerous
I
you know when
when you talk about that kind of
that whole group of guys that feel
invisible feel overlooked
I
I always think what what game is someone
playing
like what's the
what's the outcome if the outcome is I
want to sleep with as many people as
possible and I want to be the life and
soul of the party I want to be the
person that has the most animal
attraction
then you're going to struggle
because not everyone gets to have that
yep
but
if your goal is I actually want to meet
someone who's awesome
I want to meet someone I can have an
amazing life with I want to meet someone
I can build with
it doesn't actually matter how many
people find you attractive
it matters that you find someone who
thinks you're awesome now
if you come from a place where you're so
busy focused on how shallow some women
are
or how much some women will only date up
or will only date a crossover if you're
focused on that
that is going to dictate your whole life
because you're going to be miserable
you're going to be resentful you're
going to be bitter
If instead you go you know what there
are people for whom
someone showing I someone showing up
with confidence
with kindness
with a boldness because you don't have
to be being bold doesn't mean having
money
doesn't mean being successful outwardly
being bold can just be I'm bold in life
you're someone who has a level of
Courage you're someone who has a really
beautiful level of loyalty
I know there are guys who are going to
listen to everything I'm saying right
now
and they're going to roll their eyes
because they're going to be like
try dating try actually going out there
and dating if you're me there will be
those people but
but I actually believe that I really
believe that I really believe that
you know
there are people in my company
that if they left tomorrow might be able
to go and get paid more somewhere
I can't stop that I can't stop a bigger
more attractive company coming along and
going
we're gonna pay you double
and give you more this and more that I
can't stop I can't stop it and I can't
compete with it
I cannot
I can't be the sexiest company in the
world
but
I just in my bones believe that
the people that
I'm supposed to work with long term are
the people that see how much I love them
how loyal I am to them
how much I actually care about them
that I mean it when I say something
that when I say I'm serious about
long-term relationship with them I mean
it
I know they could go to another company
tomorrow and that person promises them
the world and then six months later
they're kicked out
because that that's how that company is
like yeah we'll give you the world but
we're also going to get rid of you if if
you don't live up to every single one of
these
I know that so
I can't play the game of being the
sexiest
company in the world
but I can play the game of attracting
people with the values that
that I have that they will value and the
people that I want working for me long
time term are the people that whose
values actually match with mine
dating is no different
you you may not be apple
in the dating world
I'm not Apple in the business world
but your values they they really with
the right people they will be the thing
that makes someone go
yeah of course I could be with a guy
with more money
of course I could be with a guy who's
who's taller of course I could be
what I'd be insane to give that up
for what I get with you
and there will be some guys who listen
to that and go oh so I'm the consolation
because they'd rather be with this tall
that block that's insecurity talking
because no one has everything
no one
and that's you coming from the frame of
reference that that guy's height matters
more than the values you have there's
you coming from the frame of reference
that that guy's Money Matters more than
the values you have you've bought into
that and that's why it bothers you
that's why you feel like you're the
consolation prize it's because you
believe it
so you have to stop believing that and
I'm not talking this isn't like I want
people to understand this I'm not
talking about some soft like believe in
yourself mindset I'm really saying that
this to me is the real stuff
this is this to me is like you're tall
inside
you have a tall personality
you have tall values
when someone feels that from you and
they feel that that energy is real it's
crazy how much for so many people
what they thought they cared about
yesterday
starts to actually disintegrate
so what if you start going through life
instead of being the person that
confirms
everyone's suspicions that those things
matter more what if you were the person
that made them disintegrate because
meeting you was like this like changed
someone's paradigm
on what's actually important
and that is a thing that
anyone can do anyone but you have to
actually live by those values that I'm
talking about and you might have to make
peace with playing a longer game
because it can take time for people to
realize
how important those things are you
someone tall hot and handsome or
whatever doesn't sneak up on you they
walk through the door and a lot of
people go okay that's in this seems like
a you someone I'd want to talk to but
some of the things I'm talking about
they they sneak up on you
but when they land
it can change someone's world
I I have in my own life
started to
in the last few years really just let go
of
you know whatever the kind of
comparisons
that I might have made in the past or
the thing for myself where I thought I
didn't live up to that or I wasn't this
I wasn't I'm an introvert I'm not life
and soul of the party I'm life and soul
when I'm standing on stage because I'm
good at public speaking but put me in a
party I'm no longer life and soul I'm
never I never have been I'm never going
to be
it's not who I am there was a time when
that bothered me
I was like I should probably learn some
more social skills that make me the life
and soul of the party I want to be that
guy who can like
at a certain point in my life I said
I don't care
I just don't care
and and for the kind of person that
wants me to be that for me to be in
their lives that's not my that really
isn't my purse not my friend it's not my
male friend
and I started to learn that I'm
appreciated for other things things that
I maybe never registered were important
or things I never thought were important
about me I started to realize although
that's it those are the things
let me focus on that because spending
all this time focusing on
you know is a better looking guy going
to walk in the room is someone with more
going to walk in the room is someone you
can play that game forever and there
always will be by the way
there'll always be a Chris Williamson
who shows up with bigger biceps
you know it's like it's just the way it
is but when you're on when your worth is
not rooted in that it is the most
liberating thing in the world
I wonder how much of this is related to
age I kind of get the sense that a lot
of the rules that the internet works off
get aged out and that people mature out
of them and they learn a lot of lessons
so I need to make a little bit of an
admission because for the last 18 months
or so I have been
parroting some data from GSS that said
between 2008 and 2018 the number of men
between 18 and 30 that haven't had sex
in the last year tripled from 8 to 28
and this is true this was true GSS data
has continued to come out last week I
found the 2021 data
from 2018
28 of men hadn't had sex in the last
year
in 2022 a 2021
that had dropped down to 17 of men
the number of women that haven't had sex
in the last year aged 18 to 30 was 28
percent
in 2021
now this changes the story as far as I
can see about what's going on because
the presumption is if young men aren't
having sex this is because they're not
being chosen men tend to be the sexual
protagonists women tend to be the sexual
Gatekeepers therefore if men aren't
having sex it's because they want it but
they can't get it
if women aren't having sex presumably
it's because they can get it
but maybe they don't want it so what's
going on there why do you think it could
be the case that both young men and
young women
are struggling to have sex but
particularly the young women 28 of 18 to
30 year old women didn't have sex
during 2021
hmm
do you have a theory I'm just curious
my current working theory for a lot of
this stuff is that there's generalized
uh generalized risk aversion disorder
grad which is something I've completely
made up uh but that a world where
Netflix and Amazon Prime ubereats
doordash social media video games porn
for men specifically has turned down the
amount of risk and discomfort that most
people face in their everyday lives
that means that stepping out of the
house to maybe go to a party
well you've got the competition of the
new season of succession on HBO to
compete with you know it's a pretty high
bar it's quite a thing to convey in good
season I don't want to compete with
succession no me neither so okay well
first off I'm probably gonna leave the
house less secondly if I do go to a
party I'm going to be on my phone more
which makes me less approachable thirdly
if I am there I don't have the social
skills to be interpersonally interesting
and leave the cues the very subtle cues
that you need to in order to be able to
get people to come and speak to you
fourthly while you're there if you do
begin to flirt it's an incredibly
delicate dance that you've got to do
it's push and pull it's tease it's it's
leaving uh sort of wistful
Intrigue and playing and all that stuff
it's very delicate thing to do it's
required it's very skillful requires an
awful lot of skill to do none of these
things are being developed at the moment
and
the reason that I could see that women
particularly especially in 2021 to put
my evolutionary psychologists hat on I
would say uh increased pathology uh uh
pathogen aversion so women's discussed
threshold is lower than men's because
they are more fragile uh from
physicality standpoint um which means
that they tend to be more easily
disgusted especially by the presence of
disease I didn't know that is that real
of course of course
the women well I mean think about it
like you know how many girls get grossed
out by films compared with guys like if
you just took 100 guys and 100 girls you
would presume that more girls would get
grossed out by the same time I just
thought that was because men are more
disgusting perhaps that could also be it
yeah I didn't consider that
um but just I think the the there's
definitely a little bit of Hangover from
uh from covid
one of the other sects so all of the
stuff that I mentioned there about you
know the the social media the the
introversion this sort of time that you
spend sat on the couch watching the TV
none of that would explain a sext
difference the pathogen thing would do
I wonder how much of a
post metoo world girls are becoming
increasingly worried about being
intimate with a guy I wonder whether
we're facing a bit of an intimacy crisis
whether a girl's fire alarms uh are
maybe being triggered unnecessarily uh
in in some regards there are a lot of
stories from all over the world about
what happens if you end up being alone
with a guy and it's concerning and so on
and so forth uh which might just cause
girls to check out of the dating Market
generally
um possible I'm contributing to the to
the problem why why what are you doing
that's creeping women out no I think no
I mean I'm joking because I'm A Drop in
the Ocean but I
you know
I don't think this is true but I'd
almost like to believe that
more women are being honest with
themselves about what they are actually
looking for and when they are presented
with something that it doesn't represent
that uh and and that's not to say you
know in the age group we're talking
about there'll be plenty of women who
are just having fun and doing their
thing but
but you know for for women looking for a
relationship there's a lot of sex had by
people looking for a relationship
that isn't going anywhere
and I like I like to believe that
there's an evolution happening where
people are saying no to things that
don't represent any actual I don't think
that's true by the way no but I like it
would be nice to think that a lot more
people are saying
you know what you don't want the same
thing as me so I'm not going to keep
sleeping with you just because you're
charismatic right even though ultimately
I'm going to end up hurt at the end of
this okay so
um if the bar is raised for what women
expect from a partner especially if it's
a casual partner especially if it's when
they're young
this would cause them to not just decide
to do it because well I'm lonely or
because well he's good looking or
because well whatever yeah if they were
I and I don't think that's true but I if
I
if if people said to themselves you know
what I'm not gonna I'm gonna focus on my
North Star
what I want right now is like I made a
video recently
about someone I forget what the age Gap
was but it was a woman in her 30s who
met a guy in here like 10 years younger
he's in his early 20s and this person
was like I really want a family I want
marriage I you know but this guy's
amazing
and I just remember thinking you've
completely lost touch with your North
Star
you the chances
of now I don't care how much of an old
head this person has on his shoulders
he's 21. there's the chances of this
person
blossoming into a long-term committed
relationship of marriage and kids is
minuscule
so this just feels like you're betraying
your own
goals
and I and that happens a lot
that is one of the most common things
that happens is people lowering their
standards for something that feels good
in the moment
but does absolutely doesn't align with
their goals and a lot of the time people
are lying to themselves about the fact
that it doesn't align with their goals
because they're just happy to have
something that feels good right now and
one of the problems of of dating is that
especially if you haven't had anyone
come along in a while that has excited
you
when someone does come along but they're
in the complete wrong package you're
just you become the most biased judge in
the world you're like ah that you know
and you start figuring out you have to
do the dishes you'd love to say I'm
gonna make a fantastic dad meanwhile
he's never once suggested that he even
likes kids yeah precisely pushes them
into open traffic
um so I mean the bottom line man is that
with that data and this is the first
time that I've spoken about it on the
show and it's a big deal to to reverse
that trend from you know guys being the
ones that were having less sex 18 to 30
to girls
um 2022 will be fascinating I think
we'll be out the other side of the cobit
stuff but the bottom line is that
that's what the GSS data says and it's
pretty reliable and everybody every
single person was totally happy to
accept when it was guys that were on the
receiving end of this sexlessness crisis
but it seems like you know in 2021 83
percent of guys aged 18 to 30 did have
sex at some point during that year so we
need to concede okay that something is
going on something has changed and it's
it's women that are being averse to this
um
I I really don't know what's going on
but one of the things that we've spoken
about so much has been online dating
somewhere around between 40 and 60
percent of relationships now begin
online
what are you hearing from women about
their experiences with online dating and
messaging and guys demeanor and what
they're getting right and wrong well I
think that you could
you you could caricature things a little
and say that there's
an enormous number of guys who go to
dating apps for sex
and that it's less likely that on mass
and it depends on age group obviously
but
an age where people tend to start
looking for relationships and women
start to really seriously think about
well I do actually really want a
relationship I'm not saying men don't
get to the same point but
I believe that there's more guys who are
on dating apps just going I'm just here
because I want to hook up
and
that
that I think results in a lot of just
people are just completely misaligned
when they're talking in those places
there's a lot of guys there's a lot of
bad behavior from guys who are hiding
behind the screen we know that
and that's because they're able to do
things that wouldn't that would never
dare do
out there in the world how's that
affecting women
how's that affecting their behavior
their viewers I think excuse their
perception of what guys are actually
like
because
they're getting they're getting that
from a a proport a decent proportion of
guys and it's making them think well
there are no there are no decent guys
like this is
this is just horrendous
but
there are decent guys
and they may be they may those guys
unfortunately May some of them at least
will feel completely overlooked in those
places but there's an awful lot of women
I think that Come Away with a really
tarnished view of what men are like
and I also think like some for some guys
I mean maybe for all but what they do in
that environment when they feel like no
one is there's no repercussions
I feel like that's indicative of how
they
actually feel about women or how they
you know well that's indicative of their
deeper relationship
with women
because or or in ignorance it could just
be an ignorance too that they're not
educated they've never been taught this
is this is what it's like to be on the
receiving end
of this like this is what that
experience actually is I don't think
most men actually have any bearing on
that when they're doing it and it's not
all men but the men that do it I think
they're they're not connected to the
effects of that okay so step into the
guys who are struggling with dating
online
what should they be doing if they want
to be effective at convincing a girl
that they are in this for the right
reasons that they are a guy of value and
virtue
what should they be doing when they're
texting making an attractive dating
profile communicating backward and
forward
I mean for me I think the ultimate thing
is that there's a sense of
decisiveness when it comes to
progression
you know instead of being the guy that
texts back and forth with someone for
two weeks
and there's plain chicken with like
who's gonna ask who to do something and
actually meet in real life
be the person who actually advances it
I'm not saying
in ways that suddenly make us seem
desperate but
you know you be the person that suggests
getting on the phone or meeting up for a
quick coffee like that that's a pretty
that shows intent it's a good first date
idea
some of the favorite ones
I like anything where you are not
sitting kind of facing each other I
don't I think roller coaster
yeah I remember saying this at an event
and just I go I go you know a good day
is like park bench style like anywhere
where you can sort of face out into the
world and turn to each other when you
want to talk and I just heard a voice in
the crowd go sushi
it was like the guy had just like he
couldn't he really got it yeah he was
like he just really connected with as
well that's what I'm gonna do next sushi
yeah it really cracked me up I but you
know anything that I like if you're
gonna go to a restaurant on a date sit
at the bar
it's a much better thing that going to a
table is awkward sitting across from
each other and you're staring at each
other the whole time go sit at the bar
because then you can ex you can chat
with the bartender
you can turn and say something but you
don't have to position your entire body
towards someone but it what it allows to
happen is a more natural kind of you
know if you look at attraction and
seduction it kind of we start facing
away from each other we become aware of
each other like a sort of side eye oh
I'm aware of you and then eventually we
turn into each other and I think that a
date can almost kind of you've you've
already got the we know each other part
unless you're just approaching someone
out there in the world
but
a date where you can start
pointed at something and the more
Rapport you build and the more comfort
you build you kind of end up turning
inwards that's a pretty good date so
walking is a good date like walking
somewhere with someone I think as a guy
you have to you have to also bear in
mind that for women's safety is a big
thing so being somewhere where they feel
like
where they actually feel safe with you
so not walking in a dark alleyway no no
dark Alleyways so for zero dark alleyway
first date policy okay fine cool
yeah those are those are and also not
don't be afraid to have a short date
you know if you can lower the stakes for
someone going into a date 30 minute walk
in a coffee yeah like even even you know
I have to be in this part of town later
in the day but I'm you know I'm over
here do you want to meet up for a coffee
like that just says to someone I don't
have to worry I don't have to think
about whether I want to spend an entire
evening with this person right now
the more you can lower the stakes you
only have to think of regular social
interactions if you make a new friend
it's you kind of want to build up to
things because it's hard to hang out
with a new friend it takes effort and
it's not you're kind of you know you
don't have that Comfort where you're
just like let's just hang out on the
sofa for a few hours and just chill like
that but if you say you know let's let's
grab a coffee let's grab a juice
whatever it's and they there's an out
you're more likely to have half an hour
with a new friend and that half hour can
be the making of a new friendship but
you've got to get you know as Sean acre
would put it in the Happiness Advantage
you have to lower the activation energy
required and that can apply for dating
too what have you seen with regards to
online dating profiles good ones bad
ones oh man I'm so not close to dating
profiles
but
for me
show don't tell is an important rule in
dating profiles you know that whenever
we say we're something
would tell if I say I'm like I'm funny
I'm not showing you I'm fine I'm not
saying anything that's funny I'm just
telling you I'm funny or when we're just
saying what we like listing things we
want in a person
like I want someone who's funny that's
it's
it's it becomes vanilla very quickly
because sort of isn't everybody
I think that real estate is space to
actually show something about your
personality or who the the way that you
think there was a great dating profile
that I once came across
and this woman said the prompt was
something like what's your
biggest disappointment
and she said that my future kids
will never get the experience of walking
around Blockbuster Video and choosing a
movie for the night
I always thought that was such a great
thing to say
because
that firstly she was showing like that
was endearing it was like a it showed a
nice part of her personality
she also managed to say that she wanted
kids in a completely relaxed way
not don't message me if you don't want
to be serious
like no casual you know when people put
like no casual hookups it's like you
don't need to say that
you you can just somewhat that intention
of yours will announce itself as you
start to talk to someone if they behave
badly you don't need to say it up front
you you don't want an Ax Murderer either
but you're not saying that why are you
not saying that because you've been
burned in the past by someone who just
wanted a casual hookup with you so now
all you'd put in someone's mind is that
you've you're frustrated by the amount
of casual hookups that you've had to
have in the past because you wanted more
and they didn't like that's not that's
not what you want to put in someone's
mind is the things you're frustrated
with
in dating
so what she did was she she just very
elegantly said yeah I want a family my
kids are in my future
but I don't read that and go
it was because there's no Edge to it
it's the same I had a course years ago
and there were back years ago when I
started
I actually used to send people out for
the night women out for the night and
have them practice things I don't do
that anymore there's too many people in
it it was 2 000 people in an event we
can't send have them descend me on the
city yeah yeah yeah but back when it was
small groups we actually like encouraged
people go out for the evening and try
this stuff
and it was really interesting there were
two single mums who came in the next day
and
one of them said how do I communicate to
someone that I am a single mum
it was a lot of like it felt heavy to
her
she saw it as baggage
there was another story where a woman
stood up and she goes so I was talking
to this guy
and I I liked him so I was started
initially like I immediately started
flirting with him and the first thing I
said when I spoke to him was your
chindimpo is really adorable it's not
quite as adorable as my daughter's cheek
dimples but it's pretty adorable
he had managed in the first line
to communicate that she was a mum
and have it be flirtatious
whereas someone else in the room was
going
how do I communicate
that I'm a single mother like she had
like Darth Vader waiting at home when a
guy was going to come over
that to me is fascinating and I think
dating profiles are a great place
they're a great kind of revealer of
what's our current mindset how playful
are we how lightly can we take ourselves
how lightly can we take our own baggage
like these are a lot can be communicated
in a few words that way we'll get back
to talking to Matthew in one minute but
first I need to tell you about manscaped
manscaped lawnmower 4.0 is the best ball
and body hair trimmer ever created it's
got a Cutting Edge ceramic blade to
reduce grooming accidents a 90 minute
battery if you want to take a longer
shave or if you're just a particularly
hairy gentleman waterproof technology
which allows you to groom in the shower
and an LED light which illuminates
grooming areas for a closer and more
precise trim it's even got the 7000 RPM
Motor with quiet stroke technology so
that you could secretly do it when no
one else realizes it's got a wireless
charging system which helps the battery
to last even longer basically if you're
a man in 2023 who is still trimming his
gentleman's area with an old face shaver
from five Christmases ago what are you
doing come and join us in the modern
world there are purpose-built tools for
the job and the manscape lawnmower 4.0
is exactly what you need head to
manscaped.com Modern wisdom and use the
code modern wisdom at checkout to get 20
off everything and free shipping that's
manscaped.com modern wisdom and modern
wisdom a checkout speaking of kids we're
seeing more and more women
not having children
is this something that you're noticing a
women saying that they don't intend on
having families that are in the groups
that you work with
I don't see that but I have to assume
there's a that has to be true on some
level if you take a society where
it's less
there's I won't say it's not frowned
upon at all because there's a kind of no
matter how far we've come there's always
going to be families and Societies in
which women have to deal with the fact
that something must be wrong with you if
you don't want to have kids something
must be wrong with you if that's not in
your path or that hasn't happened for
you they're always going to face that
from somewhere
but to a far lesser extent than before
and if it's to a far lesser extent than
before then naturally you're going to
have people who never wanted kids or
don't feel like they want to be they
that's not their path who are going to
feel more comfortable actually following
that so I have no doubt that number must
have risen but
you know the
a huge proportion of of my audience are
people who
would like to find a relationship and
part of what they would part of what
they want and their dream is to find
someone that they love to have kids with
like that's the I think probably
I don't have data on this but I
I would imagine
that because
women are pushing it later
which can either be which is a kind of
combination of pursuing careers societal
expectations not being the same or being
looser and
and even just the availability of egg
freezing and other methods that there's
a kind of feeling of I can
delay this but I know from first-hand
experience with not only women but on my
podcast
um love life we had two fertility
doctors who came on and talked about
this
that
there are a lot of people who just kind
of there's a almost a feeling of oh well
I'll get to it and but
so the we all know that in life when we
just decide we're now going to do
something life doesn't always cooperate
and if we're leaving the time until
later if women especially are leaving
the time till later where they suddenly
decide like okay now I'm gonna do this
and they haven't met someone yet and
they've got to go through three more
guys that don't pan out to get to the
one that does
that that can I've seen I've seen a lot
a lot a lot of people end up grieving as
a result of that and by the way the same
is true of a lot of men who assume
mistakenly that they're good
um good I can wait and wait and wait and
wait and wait and then it comes down to
it and their sperm count is too low or
you know uh the what's the I don't know
what the medical term is for slow
swimmers but you know it's that they're
not they're not in a place of fertility
where it's their sperm is viable in the
way that they thought it would be they
thought oh I'm I'm the done deal part of
this equation
or they have more complications because
they waited a long time you know which
is that seems to reflect the data that
I've seen so a very very large chunk of
women who make it to adulthood break
through the fertility window and don't
have kids didn't intend to not have kids
it's around about eight out of ten women
who end up being childless that didn't
intend right to be childless run about
10 of women physiologically uncapable
incapable run about 10 of women intended
to not have kids which leaves four out
of five
that didn't and the word grief which is
what you used is precisely correct that
they grieve for families that they never
had and the support groups Jody day uh
who runs one of the biggest in the world
is coming on the show in a couple of
weeks time and uh
it's it's it's wild and I one of the
concerns that I do have at the moment is
this current Trend that we're seeing of
um
demonizing motherhood I would say in
some regard that
um you know the newly acquired
Liberation that women have had to be
able to go and achieve a career and get
education and employment status and all
of this stuff is is phenomenal
but to see that as if you choose to be a
mother that's you
settling you're choosing to be a
second-class citizen in some regard and
you know for every culture there is a
counter-culture movement for every
patriarchal stay in the kitchen you're
not supposed to go and go to university
college and get a career there is now a
movement I mean Chelsea Handler I don't
know whether you've seen the videos that
she's been putting out the trending
online it's a video of like what it's
like to be a woman in her 50s who
doesn't have a family and for Chelsea
Handler she very well may be the right
person she may have made the complete
right life choice she talks about how
she's going to get on rare find a guy
for tonight smoke weed masturbate fall
back asleep fly to Paris buy a croissant
and I'm like
is this really the [__] future that
most women aspire to have masturbation
and croissant yeah it was blazed out of
your mind she did a clap back video a
couple of days ago where she was pouring
an entire bottle of Gray Goose into what
looked like a massive NutriBullet flask
I was thinking to myself like you're an
adult infant like you're like you're the
same of The Man Child that you would
accuse men of being and my concern is
that given the fact that we know the
largest metro analysis that's ever been
done
said eight out of ten women who end up
not having kids didn't intend to not
have kids
were already fighting against slow life
strategy which is what you mentioned
sort of pushing that fertility window
out
we're already making it it's difficult
to you may need to cycle through a
number of Partners before you can find
the right person to end up settling down
and having kids with
I don't disagree
that some dystopian [__] handmaid's
tale-esque scenario where you're forcing
women into the bedroom so that they can
pump out babies that's wrong
but given the fact that 8 out of ten
women say that they wanted to have kids
and couldn't it's also really wrong to
tell women that they shouldn't be having
kids or that having kids is settling or
that
they become a a domestic prostitute if
they choose to do that and this is a
trend that is really really picking up
steam there's a tick tock called girl
with a list have you seen this no the
girl who printed out a list of 350
reasons as to why she didn't want to
have kids and it goes all the way from
can't wear cute heels anymore to baby is
literally a parasite inside of me to all
manner of like and it's got millions and
millions and millions of tags and plays
on Tick Tock and I'm like
I don't disagree that this is
interesting content that's going to grab
attentions and headlines
but the real world outcome of this in 15
years time when the 28 year old girls
that are watching this
a bit older is
concerning to me what I hear in all of
this
is it's a kind of version of what men go
through in a different way
where if we're not careful we're we're
sold
the life that we should have and if you
take
you know we talked about the percentage
of guys that feel overlooked
if you take the opposite end of the
spectrum the guys that have an enormous
amount of choice
many of them
will be sold culturally on this idea
that if you can
you should you should sleep with as many
people as possible you should live it up
you should you know just
don't don't settle anytime soon delay
delay delay
and
that
you have to be a pretty strong person
to go
I don't think that's the answer
just because I can
it doesn't mean I should and I'm not
even saying that from a moral or ethical
place I'm for myself selfishly just
because I can
it doesn't mean that's going to make me
happy
and
women will you know they already do find
themselves in a place where they're
having to really get in touch with what
they
want
and try to
shut out the noise
and I I find myself
I find myself very conflicted
on this because
there's nothing I
there's nothing I hate more than the
idea of a woman who
doesn't have the independence herself
to be able to walk away
because I've seen that and I've seen the
utter destruction of lives where women
don't have enough financial Independence
or or the ability to continue with a job
or a business
and so that that man has something he's
holding over her the whole time and it
is the Mandate for abuse
those relationships
um
so on one hand I I the idea of
you know
kind of saying motherhood should be
celebrated I agree with but
I know if I had a daughter
I would want her to never be in a
position where she needed a man
financially
where she was always going to be okay on
her own because that's power
past that point
that's when
you have to start getting really honest
with yourself and saying do I need more
if I've already got my Independence and
now I can choose for love and I can stay
for love instead of staying out of fear
it is more necessary
and everyone faces that at some point in
their life I mean guys face that all the
time it's getting in touch with yourself
and going what do I actually want
in my life you could just keep going and
going and going and going you have the
potential you have the ability you have
everything you've got a winning hand
right you could just keep going
it's an interesting question we all have
to ask at some point which is what does
what's good for me what kind of Life do
I actually want because of course I
could keep going more is all available
always available but more time isn't
and and I think that's
when I look at
women in motherhood I just think
is trying to quiet the noise
going what is it I actually
want with my life I've had to do that me
and Audrey have had to really think
about what do we want with our lives
like what's what kind of Life are we
looking for how much does that involve
us working what's going to make us
happier at the end of the day I it's no
secret like when I thought I for most of
my life when I thought about kids I was
like sweating
just oh my God this is terrifying I
don't know like I've got friends of mine
who from the age of 22 male friends of
mine who were like
I'm I want kids I know it I want to be I
spoke to Matthew McConaughey a week ago
and he was like I always know my biggest
dream was to be a dad I cannot relate
[Applause]
but
when Audrey and I sit down we're like we
look at all of it and we go
yeah like this feels right it feels
right to do this I don't know when like
we'll figure that out that's between us
but this feels like something
this feels like it's really important to
us even if it cost us
in other ways and it will cost us in
other ways but those those are like
really adult calculations and I
I think everyone has to make them and
that demonization of people is a is a
bad thing of course I'd love to
understand your framework of how deep
lasting attraction Works say that we've
managed to get through all of the
hurdles that we've spoken about so far
and that somebody wants to get into a
relationship which has
deep blasting attraction hmm have you
got a way to break the very large
Behemoth that is being attracted to
somebody into component parts
well I always said that attraction is
perceived uh attraction is is chemistry
plus perceived value
plus perceived challenge
plus connection
right so physical you can exchange
physical attraction for chemistry but
you know physical attraction uh
perceived value perceived uh Challenge
and connection haven't said it in a
while but I I really think those four
things are
they're pretty reliable as the
components for attraction you need some
physical attraction
this person needs to bring value to your
life
and that can come in a number of ways so
that's perceived value
and perceived is an important word
because
if you can be valuable we all are but if
you don't know how to
Market your value
then No One's Gonna see it if you don't
know how to put forward your best foot
people are not going to know how great
you are it's no one's job to like
excavate
how great you are you have to be able to
actually show someone so perceived value
perceived challenges
making sure that value isn't free
that there actually is a price to pay
for that value
why is that important
because we don't value what we don't
have to invest in
if something if
if you went on a first date
and based on her picture
or her pictures and you thought she was
so gorgeous
you showed up with a brand new car for
her on the first date and said I bought
you a car
it would freak her out
she'd think this person's mental and the
reason she'd think that is because she
had done nothing
to earn that amount of value
and that's when we say someone seems
over eager or desperate what we're
really saying is that they're giving an
unearned amount of value
they are showing up for me in ways that
it's not appropriate to show up for me
given how much I'm giving to them
and that's the classic people pleaser
I'm I'm suddenly doing all of falling
over myself to try to serve this person
who I really isn't doing anything to
earn that there's not an equivalent
exchange in value
so perceived perceived challenge makes
us value someone's value
because we realize that they have
standards around it
the and having standards around your
value is essential otherwise
you you'd have no time in life you'd
have no energy you're just bleeding out
everywhere all the time and when someone
realizes you're bleeding out for them
exclusively
because they're just so hot or they're
so charismatic or they're so something
our value goes down in their eyes
because we go oh they must not this
person must not have a lot of value
because look what they're doing for me
I'm not doing that for them
I'm not doing the equivalent I haven't
even thought about them in the last two
weeks but look at what they're doing for
me
that's crazy you know so we love now we
lower their value in our eyes
so we at least question it so that's
perceived Challenge and connection is
okay we have animal attraction but do we
actually have a shared world view do we
you know is there a compatibility here
uh that is going to make us last
so
the question is how do you maintain all
of those things over time and that's
what you know Esther perel has obviously
written great books about this she talks
about the difference between love and
desire desire is love is the coming
together of two people desire exists in
the space between two people so if you
are just constantly like this and
there's never a space between you then
that mystery that fuels desire is no
longer allowed to it doesn't have the
oxygen to breathe
and that's the to me that's the Great
that is the great challenge of a
long-term relationship I actually think
that
we
we kind of pathologize familiarity like
it's a that's the curse is being
familiarity breeds contempt but
familiarity
if it's done right can breed enormous
richness you can really get to like you
anyone who's really had a successful
marriage will say that there are just
getting one of the great Joys who's been
year after year getting to know even
more about their partner
their unique facets that other people
don't see don't know about
they've built a bond that is
extraordinary now that alone won't give
you the the animal
desire that is also needed for a
long-term sexual relationship but it
will give you a level of connection with
someone that is just so weighty
that the idea of giving it up
is
the equation always is weighted
on the side of staying as far as
physical attraction goes I think that
there is a
on one it's like on one hand you have to
do the things that allow you to maintain
it on some level
if you know what that's different for
every couple and it certainly isn't
limited to Cosmos articles on get this
new try this new sex position as a way
of like it's it's a lot more nuanced
than that you know maintaining
attraction on that level or desire on
that level could be that we haven't we
haven't been out to an event with each
other in the last three months or or all
of covid and
we go out to an event together and I
actually watch you go over and talk to
other people and I get to observe you
again and I observe the way other people
receive you and how you make other
people laugh or how you're looked at by
other people and then go oh yeah she's
she's a sexy person in the world I'd
forgotten living at home for a year and
a half or so you know like that that's
what happened to a lot of people
and I think the invert the other side of
that is to say I need to Rob myself of
a kind of
this expectation that I have that
everything is supposed to stay the same
and that you have to remind yourself of
how much being single sucked a long time
ago
like that there was a time when you were
single and you maybe could sleep around
or did sleep around and
it probably didn't live up to your
expectations either
like that wasn't some unbelievable you
know you you were living this
unbelievable life and even if you were
even if you were a rock star
and you were living this extraordinary
life of sleeping with a different person
every other night I I haven't met many
people especially ones that feel
anything like me
who tell me Happy tales about that like
after a while they either get anxious
because it's like I just feel weird and
I'm gonna get someone pregnant this is
gonna happen that's gonna they're just
freaked out or they're in a place where
it's just boring because they go oh yeah
it's just another body
ultimately that's all this ends up being
is then there's no Nirvana on the other
side of this
so
I think we glor the longer we get away
from something like that the more we
glorify it
and the more we think I'll remember that
time like Grass Is Always Greener yeah
and it wasn't even that green then
like it probably wasn't you know maybe
you had a Heyday but I guarantee you
that Heyday had a shelf life and at
least with this situation there's you
can point to unbelievable things that
you like I'm a
I'm not someone who says everyone should
be in a relationship but
I am positive in my life of how much
better my life is
in my relationship like how much it
brings to me that that equation is one
decisively every single time by what I
get out of being in this relationship
and I think when people lose connection
to that
that's when they that's when they get in
trouble so it's as much about connecting
to that as well how can you stay
grateful for the things that a
relationship is bringing you because any
of us especially Taipei
people who are all about optimization
and what's the next thing
we are really good
at getting to a level that at one point
was like our dream or not even
conceivable
no 15 year old Chris wouldn't conceive I
bet of where you are today but
you're probably also a great normalizer
and if you're a great normalizer that is
not a use that's a useful skill in
business
because you just you never get too
impressed with yourself and you just
keep going
in a relationship there's a really
dangerous
part of of people like that and I count
myself as one of them because you
there can be this done
I did that part and you know so what's
the what's the optimization from here
but you
the optimization now is a vision that
you build together it's not like I I'm
optimizing still for the person
I think people optimize too long for the
person actually talking about talking
about that from a personal standpoint
and your growth now millions and
millions of clients that you've worked
with in this illustrious career of
Internet
work and exposure and plays and all the
rest of it
how are you personally avoiding getting
caught up in external metrics of success
and what have you learned about where
sort of genuine happiness and success
fulfillment comes from
Ike i my like the word that I just keep
coming back to in my life now is
Simplicity and me and my partner say it
all the time we're just like simplicity
like what
what's going to complicate our life for
very little gain
and what's going to simplify in a way
that just keeps reducing our life to
this just of where all the good stuff is
and for me the good stuff is
my relationships with my family my
relationship with Audrey it's doing work
that I feel passionate about instead of
work that just gets me ahead
that's a big one let's get you ahead
you know there was a time when for me it
was about survival it was about like I
need to feel secure because I don't feel
secure financially yeah when I was
growing up we were not secure it was a
there was you know it was a difficult
situation at times so
for me I so much of my life was about
trying to feel safe
and
and it's a hard transition to make
actually between trying to feel safe and
then now trying to feel fulfilled
because it's that engine if you're not
careful it just keeps going and going
and going but
I these days I just I I want to do work
that I'm really really really passionate
about I want to be connected to it it's
one of the reasons why I like in my work
now if you look at a lot of my videos in
the last year or two
they have a dating rapper on them so
much of it is about trauma so much of it
is about overcoming
the the wiring that we have that makes
us unhappy or makes us anxious or makes
us stressed or makes us continually go
for the wrong people or stay in toxic
situations I I talk about that because
not because it's popular I talk about it
because I feel it's really really
important and helping people in their
mental health that way is important to
me so I
for me that's that's what's important
and I'm not going to say I don't get
drawn in to the metrics because that's a
constant on I have to have a very firm
compass
that I connect to every morning
that reminds me and connects me to this
is this is the stuff that actually
matters
because otherwise that part of me that
that masochist
he will take over
and make all of our Lives miserable
because I I caught that part of me that
stresses and is anxious and is feeling
like Rome's burning even when Rome
hasn't been burning for a while
that part of me is not just bad for me
it's like not I'm not good company when
I'm like that I'm not good to the people
I love I'm not I'm not like a calming
presence for people I'm not someone who
I'm not able to access
the best parts of me the most generous
parts of me because I'm just it's a loop
of
like
fear and anxiety and all of that and
that's been a really
it's been a big thing in my life and
I've had to really work on that for
myself I continue to work on that for
myself
because it disconnects me from
everything that's actually important
and living in LA or Austin or any of
these places not good for it
because you're around people who are
doing awesome things
and there's always someone who's doing
more and there's always someone who's
eclipsed whatever you've done and you
you it takes a lot to be like
that doesn't takes a lot to leave the
party where someone just told you
something awesome they're doing and go
yeah I don't want to do that
how do you stop that external comparison
game
I well I've I'm fortunate to be in a
place in my life where I've
it's not worked enough times that I
I realize oh it's not
if I was doing that wouldn't change
anything it would make me any happier do
you mean that you've
seen a mountain that you thought was
good to Summit got to the top of it and
realized yeah you know I I came I when I
first came to La 10 years ago I came for
a TV show called Ready For Love and it
was a huge deal huge TV show executive
produced by Eva Longoria it was like
this was gonna be the show and
it got canceled after three episodes is
that your fault
um I think I was the best part of the
show
it was going to be one episode I
but it got canceled and I a year of my
life that was spent working on this
thing that was supposed to be huge just
kind of
and there were all these people that
wanted to know me for the time that it
was big and you know when it was like
everyone was coming out managers and
agents and this and that
and I really got the full I got the full
Hollywood experience
you're so important and then
no one's picking up the phone I like I
went through that whole thing in a in a
space of a year and a half and it was
it was great
it was like the best thing that could
have happened to me at 25 when when that
happened it was so great thank God
it wasn't a hit
I because it wouldn't have been good for
me
it absolutely wouldn't have been good
for me
like I might have blown my life up like
I I just couldn't trust myself at 25. to
handle that
and
as I look back now and I'm just like
but when I when I was up there it didn't
make any
difference it was just like it was
it was exhilarating in certain moments
just like anything is that's you know
has that drug effect
and and then it's nothing it's available
being on love Island that I did the
first season first person through the
doors of season one
and it was 10 times bigger season two
and then ten times bigger than that
season three and then ten times even
bigger than that season four so I
basically did a full production fully
broadcast dress rehearsal for all of the
remaining ones that were actually
successful
but I'm so grateful for the fact that I
came off and there was 5 000 more
followers than when I went on no one had
about the show nobody gave a [__] no one
gave a [__] about it because if it if
I'd managed to find success
doing reality TV
I would have ended up being pigeonholed
into a life of that is how you got
success replicate that formula to
achieve more
but because it wasn't something that I
generated it was something that had been
given to me like make no mistake for
every single person out there that
thinks that going on reality TV is the
answer to their problems you are
basically like the Mockingbird the
Mockingjay [__] foreign
like that's what you're hoping for
you're hoping to be plucked out of the
lottery and gifted status on the top of
a hill
but it's not you you're not manifesting
you forward
you're being squeezed into the shape
that is prefabricated because the show
knows what it needs itv2 knows what they
need out of this show the same as your
thing when you came to LA and the same
as whatever else it is
if it's not
completely generated by you and that's
not to say that people can't go on these
shows and enact themselves forward and
be interesting and whatever but for the
most part you're being very heavily
squeezed into a
odd shape that you have to fill and if
you've been taught through life
experience oh well that's how you get
success not rinsing and repeating that
is going to be very very difficult not
to do so I am
I couldn't be more grateful that my
season of Love Island was a failure yeah
well because but what you're talking
about is that you in life you can do
things that give you these spikes but
those spikes they correct themselves
right you it's over and then you're kind
of back to your life and being you and
even if you back to your life but with
more money or more something you're
still you're still waking up every
morning going what do I do today and
that's real life real life isn't you won
the lottery and now your whole life is
different forever no real life is you
still have to wake up tomorrow and
decide what to do
and
if you I think one of the to me at least
one of the great secrets is if you can
just find something that that when you
really
connect to it you realize I could do
this for a long time
like this is
I could keep doing this I think it
what I do now
and I don't mean the intensity of it
because I could say I could stand to
lose a couple of projects if I'm honest
but what I do now in terms of
every week on YouTube
I make a video and I have courses and
live Retreats and all of that and that's
an unbelievable part of my world but
reaching people and so and saying things
that make them feel better and help them
that I could just do forever I I
know that would be a life well lived for
me and I think if you can find something
like that forget the spikes forget the
Spikes play the long game with that
there's this guy this is embarrassing
but there's this guy
called I'm a bit of a like Disney geek
didn't see that coming
I I grew up like when the first time I
went to one of the Disney parks I was
like just blown away by it and it's just
never left me I is the man I am today
with all of my diverse interests I still
one of my favorite things to do is to go
and walk around the parks
there's this guy that his name's his
YouTube name is Mr Morrow
and he just walks around the Disney
parks and blocks and like video blogs
about his experience going around the
parks
and
I spoke to him on the phone because he
was such an example to me of someone who
just he figured out something he really
loved
and he was working at Denny's
fine establishment
there's some good items fine
establishment I didn't know that Denny's
was uncool and I I started going wanting
to go there for dinner with my friends
and when I ever I said can we go Danny's
they looked at me like I suggested that
we go and kill somebody I lived for a
long time in LA opposite the IHOP on
Sunset Boulevard which is a particularly
sort of it's right in the middle of
Hollywood so it's quite a
it's like a bit of a like you know
it's just a bit grimy and I lived right
there and I used to go to that IHOP
every morning for breakfast at like 5
a.m when I was like going to because I
didn't want to work in my little
apartment so I used to go to Starbucks
right after him work and just eat in
that IHOP so I can slum it with you at
Denny's anytime you like but
he used to work at Denny's and then he
started filming these videos just going
around the parks
and I spoke to him
on the phone because I was like at one
point I really wanted him to come and
speak at one of my events because I was
like you've just figured it out I can
tell you figured something out you
figured out something you love and now
you do it for a living and
you're not you just are so grateful all
the time you don't strike me as someone
who's just looking for more more and I
spoke to him on the phone and
he just was the most
he was just the sweetest guy and he said
to me I just he was there was no there
was no one there to see it this
conversation
he just said if I could just do this
every day and just keep doing this and
I've got a couple of friends here in
Florida that you know I've made and I
walk around the parks and I film and
people really like them he said I would
just be so happy
and that I I was I welled up when he
said it
I literally got goosebumps and welled up
because there was something about it it
was so pure
and I just thought that he's figured it
out he's figured some maybe he hasn't
figured all of life out but he's figured
something out something that most people
never figure out in their lifetimes what
can I just keep doing that if this is as
good as it gets I'm good that's pretty
special
I've heard you say in the past that you
felt like you were on the outside of
your own life looking in yeah
yeah I felt like that for a while I I
think I hit like 27
and I just
I didn't
I couldn't connect
I was like struggling I was trying to
figure out what's
what's going on like why am I not
I know this is all great
but I don't feel connected to it I just
I felt very disconnected I didn't use
that word at the time
but I look back now and I was
just unhappy
just hadn't I hadn't I had done you know
there's as you well know there's levels
in life
and
depending on your circumstances
growing up or at school or whatever
level level one for you
might be
survive or do something that means you
don't have to fear
and so you kill yourself trying to do
something that means you don't have to
fear anymore or you can take care of
people that you love and that was it for
me like from early on it was just like
take care of people like the people who
are the people I love Tim let me take
care of them let me take let me make it
so that I'm secure they're secure and
let's
and and I kill myself like doing that I
said no to so much
in my 20s and and one of the things I
said no to that I didn't really realize
was just uh
I suppose true introspection like really
under I didn't I was just too it's not
like I kept saying there's all this bad
stuff that I need to process or like let
me save that till later I didn't I just
didn't
I didn't even connect to that so when I
started not feeling right
I didn't know why I just it was just
I've just freaked out I was just scared
because I thought
oh why what is going on why am I numb
like why am I not
I'm helping a lot of people I know I'm
you know people were so grateful for the
work that I was doing
I was I was independent I was able to
take care of people I love it should
have been awesome
and it and it just wasn't but um
I just had a I had a lot of things I had
a lot of work that I hadn't done I
didn't even realize was work to be done
for me the idea of like
you know the idea of therapy was some
that was for someone else
for a different kind of person I'm
killing it
you know like everything's going I work
hard I have no problem with ambition I'm
like driving forward in my life I'm
helping people I'm doing what I love
like it didn't
it just felt like oh that's a thing
other people do and
I've been very very humbled by it by
life you know over the last eight years
in just realizing
there's just
there's there's always another level
there's always something you've kind of
not figured out yet or not worked out
and I praise I applaud great therapists
not every therapist is a great therapist
but I the ones who are really good
you know I applaud them because that
work that they do with people if you can
is it you know the hardest thing in the
world is when you have someone in your
life that you love and you see them
unhappy or you see them disconnected and
you're like you you really need to go
and do this work
was that the difference then from being
on the outside of your own life to
actually feeling it was mostly therapy I
think it was a number of things I think
it it was
therapy
but it took my life
it took sort of things happening that
affected me immensely or it took an
immense amount of pain
for me to do that
like it wasn't something I was gonna do
just because like oh let's just add this
into the portfolio I was always I was
always someone who took courses I was
always someone who did self-development
I was always like that was just me but
it was all Taipei stuff you know what I
mean it was all like
optimization and getting ahead and
learning it was never like
going inwards and and that's because it
I was so focused on that feeling of
getting out of danger all the time of
like let me just get somewhere secure
let me just get somewhere where I can
control things where we have enough
money where we have enough that I
the inward work didn't feel like it had
any return
didn't feel like what am I gonna like
I'm gonna sit in therapy for hours and
hours and hours like what's the what's
the return on that and I think that that
happens to a lot of people there's no
obvious Roi
on that so it's like yeah I'll save that
like I could do that later which is why
in some ways for some people it's
actually
I want to be careful how I say this but
it's unfortunate in a way
that
if they never really get punched in the
face by life
because if you don't hit a certain pain
threshold and you're the kind of person
that thinks you've always got it
together and you can always function
which is how I was I was like highly
functioning
if something doesn't bring you to your
knees then you
you may never make that decision to do
that work and you may always live in a
disconnected way that deprives you of
what how rich and how beautiful life can
really be I love life
and always have loved life
but there were times where I couldn't
connect to that love
and
and so you know for me it was just
realizing oh I'm not something's not
right and and I'm not gonna
be able to deal with this
unless I do something about it and it
forced me to slow down it forced me to
say that hour that I take away from work
today
to go and sit in someone's office
and do this is more important than
anything else was there a single moment
that brought you to that
I mean multiple I you know that having
that realization that I didn't feel like
that truly having that realization like
that that was a moment I I dealt with
chronic physical pain
for a long time
which is still a part of my life it's
not like it's fully eliminated but it's
I had a I had a long time dealing with
chronic pain in my head
that I'm pretty convinced was a rose out
of
not dealing with stuff and not dealing
with stress and not like I'm pretty
I'm not someone who used to be a big
believer in you you I think spent enough
time with me to hear I'm a pretty
rational
person I need logic to make sense for me
to get on board I but I
I've had enough experiences now to
realize oh you can really do a number on
yourself
if you don't figure certain things out
if some things like create intention in
you
if something's if you're not processing
something or dealing with something then
you you like your life your body
something will find a way Aaron
Alexander is nodding his head along to
this at the moment right right
it something will happen and for me it
was a throbbing pain in my head that
just never went away and and uh and and
other symptoms too which I I won't
mention just because it's the kind of
thing that people once you say it
everyone wants to give you a
thing you should do you know you should
drink celery juice you should take ice
baths you should do this you should do
acupuncture you should like I've been on
that entire Journey for years so it's
not I don't need suggestions
but
um but it but it was so it was so bad
it was so bad this wasn't I'm not
talking like it it kind of intruded on
my life it took over my life
and
it robbed me of of my joy it really
couldn't
figure out how am I ever gonna be happy
again like I really I even said at one
point to the therapist that I was seeing
I came in one day and I was like
I
I've come to the conclusion
that for as long as this pain exists I'm
never gonna be happy
because I can't sleep properly I can't
experience
any of the good stuff in my life
I can't focus it is just there 24 7 and
it
I've come to the realization that I may
never be able to be happy again
so I'm just gonna live for other people
I'm gonna live for my family I'm gonna
live for the people that I'm helping I'm
gonna live like
and I he just looked at me and he went
that is
it's not he the first sentence he said
is that is Hallmark
depression but he said it's not
it's a circumstantial depression it's a
rising out of chronic physical pain but
what you just said
is
is real depression
and
and that that's language I would never
have used about myself
I didn't relate to anxiety or depression
like they weren't words in my vocabulary
and yet I came to realize in my life
I've always had anxiety
and depression was something I was
experiencing then in a really serious
way
and
foreign
taking over your life to the point where
you go
it's not like I was having suicidal
ideation but when some when you kind of
have a thought that I don't know how I'm
going to do this
I don't know
how I'm gonna if this stays this way
for the next 50 years of my life
I don't know what I'm gonna do
and that
that was terrifying for me like truly
terrifying and it felt to me like
becoming an adult in a weird way I'd
been an adult for a long time and I'd
have to I'd had to handle my my stuff my
own life for a long time I'd had to rely
on myself for a long time but
but it felt like a time in my life where
it was like the truest realization that
no one is coming
no my family would look at me in so much
pain and feeling so
depressed and not know how
what do I do
this person I love so much is hurting so
badly
and they're like a zombie
what did what do I do
and when the people that love you the
most are throwing their hands up because
they're so helpless
to be able to help you you you realize
like oh my God no one's coming
this is an and it was my first I tried
everything
and it was my first like brush with
something where my type A
I can't fix this
I don't
I've always been able to outwork any
problem
and
this is not working
on this one
and it
I went through all this day I went
through Panic like sheer panic
to you know grief to
my life is over to I went through all of
that and I'm not talking six months I'm
talking like for for years this went on
and I just functioned really really well
thrill
um
but the more I worked on my own piece
like truly worked on my own piece
the more it started to sort of
like ease up it was almost like
like tension went away and it started to
ease up and
it's gotten to a place now where I'm
like you don't understand I couldn't
have had this conversation with you
before
this is not something I would have said
to anyone that this would have made
great content
to talk about this for the years that it
was going on it would have been amazing
talk about this vulnerable
it I couldn't speak about it to anyone
publicly the only people that I talked
to about it were my friends and family
because
I couldn't trust that information in the
world and people
I couldn't trust anyone in the street
coming up to me and talking to me about
it and that I would be able to handle
that
so me talking about it now is like a I
still don't want everyone coming and
talking to me about it really
you know it still there's a part of me
that's like I don't even want to talk
about this because
I don't want it to be a topic of
conversation
um it's a very personal thing to me but
but I'm able to talk about it because
I've I've managed to find
a completely different level of Peace in
my life and what I've learned
through this whole process in life is
that
everything that we're struggling with
has a very you know my pain my physical
pain
has a very real component to it right
there's a there's
a portion of it that's just
physiological it sucks
but
my emotional relationship with that was
making it a thousand times worse
and once I was I had to run that I had
to like truly go through that Journey
which is the for me the most I suppose
I'm not a person who uses the word
spiritual very much but it was the most
spiritual journey of my life to have to
learn to come to terms with that and
make peace and
coexist with it and build a relationship
with it that was positive instead of
negative but but the more I did it the
more I realized that eighty percent
could be
I could figure it out
and if I could figure it out if I could
bring it down to like a six or a five or
a four
then I could have a different life with
it and and I think that's true of all of
our stuff is that we we encounter
problems in life and we think
we think the problem is this like
immovable object and it might be it
literally might be something you can't
do anything about but
people don't understand what Leverage
they have
with what the 80 is their relationship
their emotional relationship with that
problem
and now teaching that for me teaching
that to other people on things that
they're struggling with is one of the
most it's one of the things that brings
me the most Joy on my Retreats where
people come and spend six days with me
it's like the it drives me because I
know people's lives can be so much
better than
they're experiencing right now
by changing the story that they tell
themselves about the things that are
happening to them changing the story is
absolutely one of them a different story
will give you a different emotional
relationship with it
having a a different
a different mindset around it even just
understanding that
you can modulate something
like I when I when I started to learn I
can modulate this
like I can if I can bring this to a
night from a nine to a seven I can
I can actually enjoy my day more I can
live more if I could get a peaceful five
minutes maybe I could make that 10.
or an hour even I didn't think sometimes
I go I didn't think about my pain for
the last half hour
why was that what was I doing
what happened
as I enjoying myself as I distracted
did I have a bigger problem like what
just I would study it
and
and what I came to learn is
Everything Everything Changes
everything
we have things in our life that we think
I'll never get over this it'll never
change whether it's heartbreak physical
condition uh
someone dies
something happens in your business you
say I'll never get over this
Everything Changes
it modulates
and you don't know how you'll feel about
this thing in five years and you have to
we have to be very careful
because at my worst I honestly was like
checked out of life
Asaka can't do this and part of what
made it part of what turned it from a
already painful experience to one that
was intolerable
was when I told myself it'll be this way
forever
then then I was like I I freaked this
panic and panic you can't live in for
too long your body can't take your mind
can't take it so you you like it's like
you short circuit and panic just goes to
numbness just disconnection
for me one of the greatest lessons of my
life is that you just you just don't
know how this is going to change and if
it doesn't change you you don't know yet
you're not an expert on how your
relationship with it is going to change
and either way that can produce a
completely different life for you and I
know this is probably off subject for
what we were talking about today but I
just think for anyone out there who's
really struggling right now if that can
offer
not just hope but because hope can
like hope itself can be really miserable
right when you keep hoping that it's
going to get better and it doesn't If
instead you just sort of settle in
like if it sucks right now whatever part
of life sucks if you just settle in
and just strap in and just go okay it
sucks right now
but I don't know how much it's gonna
suck in five years it might I might feel
differently about this
I this might change or I might change
the way I see it everything changes
if you can get to if you can understand
that then
you suddenly have a kind of mental
formula for just
so just strapping in
it's going to strap in for now and
Jujitsu uh
there was a when I started out I was
rolling for like three minutes and then
I couldn't breathe right and I remember
my professor saying to me
you know you know some of the guys when
we're here after you we'll roll for an
hour non-stop we like set timer for an
hour
and we just roll for an hour for this
like Marathon
and I was like what are you what are you
talking about how do you how's that even
possible and he said
you know when
when you realize that it's gonna go on
for a whole hour
you kind of just you stop breathing
differently because you just realize why
I can't keep going like this
like I just have to settle in
and suddenly when you settle in it it's
a different experience then when I'm
going for three minutes and I'm like uh
like tenths tense tense 100 you you
settle in
and I think that's a pretty good
it's a pretty good way of approaching
life in general if you're anxious in
early dating and you go are they going
to text me back are they gonna tell
yourself if this is gonna work out
I'm gonna be with this person for the
next 60 years
do I want to breathe like this the whole
time
does the energy I want to have the whole
could I do this for 60 years
all right then settle in
Matthew Hussey ladies and gentlemen if
people want to check out the stuff that
you do online where should they go
well I suppose
um there's three places if someone wants
something that's just easy and free
every week my YouTube channel uh you can
find me there on my Instagram or
Facebook
if you're a woman looking for
dating advice I have a link called your
dating solution where you could
literally input your challenge and it
will give you my best solution for what
you're going through that's at
yourdatingsolution.com
and if you're a man or a woman and
you're looking for a bigger journey and
bigger life change not just your love
life but
your whole psychology and getting the
most out of your life I have a virtual
Retreat that's coming up uh that's a
three-day event for men and women and
they can find all of the information
about that at MH virtual retreat.com I
think I really appreciate you man I
appreciate the fact that you've done the
work I think that it is very cool to see
someone go through this trajectory over
time of coming out here of achieving
success of failing of success the uh
darker side of what's going on whilst
publicly still having it all together
and privately going through all of this
turmoil I think it's a very compelling
story I really appreciate the work that
you do I'm looking forward to seeing
what you do next thanks for having me
man I appreciate it and I appreciate the
work you do as well I your curiosity is
really inspiring you and I I think have
probably had a lot of similar influences
over time I you know the people that you
and I think in our 20s started to
gravitate to the Hitchens and the
harrises and the Murrays you know we I
think you and I have been inspired by a
lot of similar people and it's uh it's
fun to watch your mind work here's to
the next 10 years cheers thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks